Now to our breaking news.
A Russian jet has forced down a U.S.
drone over the Black Sea
after damaging its propeller.
CNN's Oren Liebermann is at the Pentagon
gathering details on this.
Oren,
tell us what we're learning about this.
Brianna,
this played out early this morning
over international waters
of the Black Sea.
According to the U.S., Air Force
Europe, an MQ nine Reaper drone, a U.S.
Air Force surveillance drone or a spy
drone was flying over the Black Sea when,
according to the Air Force,
two Russian fighter jets conducted what
they're calling an unsafe
and unprofessional interception.
That's just the beginning of it.
According to the Air Force,
the two Russian SU 27 flanker fighter jets
repeatedly flew in front of the MQ nine
Reaper drone, apparently in an attempt
to disrupt or disturb its flight pattern,
even dumping fuel in front of that U.S.
Reaper drone.
And then according to the Air Force,
one of those SU 27 fighter jets
damaged the propeller of the Reaper drone
forcing it down
the propeller on a reaper is behind it.
So somehow that Russian fighter jet
managed to damage the propeller,
forcing the U.S.
to bring down the drone
in international waters.
Of course,
this is a very severe incident and U.S.
Air Force Europe issued a statement
essentially essentially referencing
how severely they view this.
Let me read you a part of this.
This incident demonstrates
a lack of competence.
In addition
to being unsafe and unprofessional.
These aggressive actions
by Russian air crew are dangerous
and could lead to miscalculation
and unintended escalation.
According to the national security
Council.
President Joe Biden was briefed
on the incident earlier this morning
by national security
adviser Jake Sullivan.
So he was given that information
about how this played out.
Earlier today, according to the NSC,
there have been other interceptions
between Russian and U.S.
aircraft, but none as severe
or as potentially escalatory
as this where we see an actual collision
in midair between a Russian fighter
jet and a US drone
that forced down the US drone.
Of course, the key question now, Brianna,
how does the U.S.
respond How severely do they view this
and how deliberately do they view this?
Certainly the statement from U.S.
Air Force
seems to say that the Russians
were very deliberate
in flying in front of the drone,
dumping fuel in front of the drone
and then damaging the propeller,
forcing it down
eventually in the Black Sea.
So now we'll wait to see how the U.S.
chooses to respond to this incident.
We have also reached out to the Russian
Ministry of Defense for comment, Brianna.
In Orange, just to be clear, of course,
the Ukrainian port city of Odessa
there on the Black Sea, we don't know
specifically where this happened.
It's our understanding and it's worth
noting that we have been able
to track the flights
of many Reaper drones over the Black Sea
over the course of the war and before.
And they essentially fly
an almost circular pattern,
either
in the western part of the Black Sea,
either west of Crimea
or south west of Crimea.
We don't know exactly where this happened,
but we have seen Reaper drones
flying almost on a daily basis
since the beginning of the war.
And even earlier than that,
we know Russian jets have flown as well.
Of course, what's different
here is the interaction,
frankly, the collision between these jets.
U.S. Air Force says it happened
in international waters where both the US
and the Russians are absolutely entitled
to fly under international law,
but not like this, Brianna.
Certainly not.
All right.
Oren Liebermann,
live for us at the Pentagon.
Thank you.
Let's talk about this now
with General Mark Hertling.
He is a CNN military analyst,
former commanding general, U.S.,
your Army, Europe and Seventh Army.
And David Sanger is with us as well.
He is the White House
and national security
correspondent for The New York Times.
All right, General, first off, I mean,
just explain how significant this is.
This is
typical of shadowing and intercepts
in Europe.
Brianna, truthfully,
what you see is Russia
does this all the time
in international airspace.
On top of international waters,
Russia often considers the Black Sea
their national lake, which is dead wrong
and doesn't apply that way.
But you will see Russian aircraft
continuously
having these kinds of intercepts
or shadows,
but nothing like this.
Airplanes get close
You certainly will see.
There have been years
where there are over a couple of hundred
of these kind of things, incidents
occurring every year.
And it's normal procedure.
But when you get this close
and you interfere
with flight paths of other aircraft,
either manned or unmanned, it's
certainly not under international law.
And it's certainly going to create
quite a distraction in this campaign.
But as Orange is said, it's in Western,
possibly in western
Black Sea region to the west
of the autonomous region of Crimea.
It's just Russia, again,
interfering in international airspace
with other aircraft.
David, how do you think the U.S.
government is looking at this as they're
trying to figure out how to respond?
Well, I'm pretty
sure, Brianna, they're going to respond
pretty calmly to it.
I think they will denounce it,
but it's an unmanned aircraft,
and that means that fortunately
there are no casualties.
But I'm sure that President Biden
is going to be thinking that what he's
trying to avoid here is, of course,
is an escalation with the Russians.
Remember, his first goal in this war
has been help the Ukrainians
His second goal in this war
has been avoid escalation
and anything that could lead to World
War Three.
Now, we've had surveillance craft
taken down before.
The most famous case in modern times
was a Chinese collision
with a manned American
surveillance craft
in international waters.
As in this case, the Chinese pilot
ended up being killed in that incident.
And the Americans survived
but were taken captive
for a while,
eventually returned to the United States.
This does not rise quite to that level
because it's unmanned,
but it nonetheless tells you
that the Russians are now willing
to take more risks to push back
on the American involvement in the war.
And the question is, where does that end?
You know, where does it end?
And certainly the U.S.
is considered with escalation, concerned
about potential escalation
in here,
as we hear from the Air Force General.
But I wonder
if that isn't sort of the point.
And I also wonder
if from Vladimir Putin's perspective,
you know, something like this
happening in the black sea is perhaps
good for him, a place
where he has suffered some embarrassment.
Right.
When you think about the flagship
of the Black Sea fleet being sunk
I would not agree with that.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead, David.
Please, Mark. Go.
Go right ahead.
No, I would not agree with that.
Brianna, I think this is baiting.
I think a pilot made a mistake.
They were trying to launch said intercept,
which means escort
and see what's going on.
But when you clip an aircraft
because it's to
to either land or crash, then you've got
you've got a different situation right
now. Yes.
Russia has certainly been embarrassed
in the Black Sea with the sinking
of several vessels by a country
that doesn't have the Navy that Ukraine.
But certainly when you're interfering
with international aircraft
in international airspace,
that's not purposeful.
That's
that's beating and it's interception.
You know, this is not something
that where, again, Mr.
Putin is trying to puff up his chest
a little bit and says,
see what I can control in the Black Sea.
These Reapers were more than likely
not only looking for intelligence,
but also over watching some of the grain
and fleets that are going through
embargoed territory out of Ukraine
into the Bosphorus and up the down canal.
So these are things
that are all parts of this.
Again,
all of this is conjecture on my part,
what that reaper was doing there.
But certainly when a Russian aircraft
interferes clips
it and knocks it out of the sky,
that's a little bit more serious.
And we haven't seen one of those things
happen since this war began.
This is incredibly serious.
And I wonder, David,
how Vladimir Putin might respond
to this versus
how he might see this as something
that obvious should be avoided,
but how he might respond to this?
You wouldn't expect
that he's going to come out and give some
heartfelt apology to the U.S.
No, he's certainly not.
And, you know, think about the more recent
case of the balloon, really
another kind of surveillance vehicle
that was over U.S.
territory and China complained
when the U.S.
took it down.
But, of course, in that case,
it was clearly overt U.S.
territory.
The key part here is
this was in international waters.
One of the big questions
that Mark raises here
and you do as well is
what's the level of intent?
In other words,
did Putin himself order this?
Did the Russian military order this?
Was this a Russian pilot
who sought an opportunity
and was sort of acting on his own?
We may not know that or we may take us
a while to go figure that out.
My guess is that right now
the administration will denounce it,
but that you won't see them
take a similar action.
And the reason for that is pretty clear.
Putin has until now been pretty cautious
about keeping the war inside
Ukrainian territory.
There have been
some cyber attacks on Poland.
But other than that,
there has really been no case.
We've seen where they've gone into NATO's
territory, where they've gelled into
that kind of territory.
And I don't think Putin
wants to bring Naito into this.
So my guess is that both
sides will probably cool it down,
even while declaring
themselves in the right.